[Musik]
na endlich kommt die pizza ach ja herr
oppermann
köster ich finde sie zu sehen haben sie
sturmfreie bude ich habe schon volle
pulle
falls meine eltern jetzt früher
zurückkommen würde ich einfach sagen
dass niemand vertrauenslehrer sind okay
also ich muss ja keinen hinterausgang
benutzen ich bin der der frauen
sie können aus dem fenster klettern als
abgeordneter dürfen sie ja den
fahrdienst benutzen von daher würde ich
sagen direkt das große bier oder ich
krieg das war so wir haben eigentlich
alle accessoires die das deutsche trikot
tragen sie ja schon denn wir haben
glaube ich auch noch ein deutsches
passieren dass wir sind ja ungefähr
gleich groß weil sie sieht gut aus gehen
sie so dann auch gleich im bundestag
würde ich sagen muss ich dann doch
wieder merke dass sie keine krawatte
darüber ziehen dann ja das muss ich auf
jeden fall ich muss gleich die sitzung
leiten haben ja noch den richtigen job
ja ja ja winkel haben wir noch
deutschland schminke wir können wir
machen ja wenn sie das im gesicht haben
nachher werden sie dann auch für ein fdr
gehalten also ich habe keine probleme
mit den farben ich bin patriot großartig
und die ohren klingt ja kein machen sie
überall drauf sind wie so ein richtiger
okay das ist jetzt sehen kriegt man ja
dann immer hereinspaziert bilanzieren
studio ja klassisch aber sehr toll
improvisiert hier oder eltern würden das
nicht wieder können nähe dass es das war
auch der plan
man will sich ja nie so einrichten die
seine eltern haben sie sich zu hause so
eingerichtet wie ihre airline ist habe
ich kann den kopfball
ja sie sind besser als ich können sie
fußball spielen ja am liebsten mit
meinen zehnjährigen sohn aber auch gerne
den fc bundestag mal ne wie wird man da
aufgenommen
man meldet sich an man muss natürlich
sozusagen die werte unterschreibt für
eine achtung und respekt vor anderen ja
gibt's denn dann auch alf demichelis'
dabei ja wir hatten jetzt beim letzten
spiel hahn fdp dabei
und haben sie das auch unterschrieben
der hat das auf dem kollegium
geschrieben
und wie ist das dann wer von ihnen cloud
den ländern duschen die klamotten
das machen wir nicht sind sie von einer
mannschaft der bundesliga bin ich als
geborene westfale natürlich fan von
borussia dortmund ja nicht so looser
wieder einmal von thomas oppermann
gelöst werden 10
na gut das 1 0 haben sie aber ich
schieße jetzt noch sieben tore ich habe
auch was zu essen
aber ich habe noch gekocht genannt
restlichen waren bars und den 50 er bei
uns weisen die philips ist der neue name
sollte sich die spd nicht auch mal
einfach das prinzip der fifa zu einem
machen langfristig also stimmen einfach
kaufen
das ist kein ausweg für die sp diesen
die fifa ist nach wie vor korrupt das
ist eine ganz traurige
begleiterscheinung eines so
faszinierenden sports genauso wie die
spd manchmal eine traurige
begleiterscheinungen der deutschen
parteien politik ist die habe wir haben
eine stolze geschichte und gehen sie mal
davon aus wir kommen wieder wenn ich das
noch erleben sie werden das als junger
mann noch erleben werden sie noch
erleben
das war ich würde es auch noch erleben
ganz sicher sicherlich viel älter als
sie dabei haben sie nur wasser getrunken
genau klar was vorbereitet und zwar
vielleicht kennen sie das puste fußball
wir haben ball und dann kriegen wir
jeder einen strohhalm und daran können
wir jetzt mal gegeneinander toreschießen
wir versuchen das mal so zu halten haben
anstoss ja ich versuche mal andere stößt
das tun ja ich lasse mich gar nicht aus
der eigenen hälfte
was ist das für ein gefühl mal zu
gewinnen ja ich fürchte 41 42
wieder dass wir jetzt hier zu gewinnen
januar gehören das jetzt mal mit dem
wasserball dann haben sie es nicht so
einfach
spüren sie gewinnen ja wirklich die
ganze zeit ich fühle mich wie die spd
und wie ist das gefühl so erniedrigend
wir können ja leider kein spiel zusammen
gucken wo man einfach mal so ein paar
situationen durchspielen und wir
reagieren dann entsprechend ok
deutschland schießt ein tor
lassen sie schöner schuss sehen sie hier
kommen sie doch endlich mal wieder zum
jubeln jetzt können sie mir das
gegenteil wie bei deutschland kriegt ein
gegentor
ja so ne scheiße dann muss man das
angehen das waren fehler von hector der
hätte ihn niemals durch aber der reuss
hat ja gar nicht mitgeholfen von der
decken was kann er heute waren meine wir
sollten mal zusammen ins stadion gehen
ja wir haben ja sie können ja dann den
ständig gefahren doch mal fragen ob sie
fahren dann doch noch
wir wollen sie das möglich machen
vielleicht hat schröder für sie
entwickelt ich besorgte mir eins
ausgeschieden haben sie die nummer von
gerd schröder hat der whatsapp was ist
denn ihr plan für die nächste wahl wm
quasi wahl meisterschaft für die nächste
werk oder sellschaft ja noch ein punkt
gemacht also für die nächste wahl
meisterschaft müssen wir selbstbewusst
antreten
mit haltung aufhören mit der auto
aggressiven fixierung auf die eigenen
defizite ja das ist dann landen wir da
wo der fc köln gelandet ist das hat
keinen zweck
wir sind ja nur am rundesten ja ich habe
mich nur einige so richtig in whistler
eröffnet wir hatten sie das kann er
nicht richtig ab ja das wollen wir noch
mal tippen wer weltmeister wird
naja ich typ schritten auf deutschland
ja ich auch aber dann macht das ja
keinen sinn wir müssen sie haben es
geschafft dann wird es passiert was ist
der wetteinsatz gehst mir kiste bier ja
dann machen wir das so ich frage dann
meine eltern auch die mir einkaufen
ok ach so bisher noch so jung kiste
brause beschlossen hätten sie einen
guten ort und deswegen und zu mir im
bundestag
trinkt man den bundestag auf die strecke
bei der arbeit nicht spd gar nicht
erwartet ich trink nicht bei der arbeit
mehr kann mir jetzt ein bisschen zu
langsam die antwort ja sie haben gemerkt
dass er erst überlegt wird ja ja klar
jeder das ist also sie ja wohl noch
grillen ja was glauben sie denn lieber
fleisch oder den politischen gegner am
liebsten den politischen gegner und was
können sie besser haben sich die pause
gemerkt hälfte na dann prost ich muss
jetzt ja dann freuen wir uns auf die wm
verpassen das spiel
danke dass sie hier waren okay und
[Musik]